I just look at that and just go even
people on his own side were like hold on
a bit mate they make the truth seem
insane but what they're peddling
actually is insane we have allowed them
to make the truth seem crazier than
actual craziness we take their ideas
more seriously than they take ours but
their ideas are insane lunacy and we
lend them more legitimacy than they will
lend to us when we are speaking the
truth and they are babbling nonsense you
think this is a good strategy what is
the evidence that this strategy works we
moderate our tone we seek to kill him
with kindness while they recruit Legions
by doing exactly the opposite again I
ask you when will you learn